I really didn't like this but what did
you think I thought it was alright you
had a visceral hatred of me yeah I'm
just more like I it started off like
okay I'm not liking this but whatever
it's harmless and then somewhere halfway
I'm just like fuck this movie and I got
to the ending I'm like really fuck this
movie and I just got angry with it I
really liked and then long stretches of
just boredom climaxes with you I can
only play one character and that is
constipated there's a second viewing of
Mary Poppins returns this felt wicked
this is a nice song and that just goes
in the paintings like it's really weird
there's like no connection at all it's
like this song exists by its kiss smoke
dog you know if I'm gonna hear bad
accent I wanted to be Dick Van Dyke it's
kind of clever like well that's updated
instead of a chimney suite he's a light
lorry but all I keep thinking about that
was Burt yeah no problem throughout this
whole thing but that is the toughest
thing to work around is how do you do a
bird character could you get happer cuz
they get older I don't know how to get
around it like that's tricky I love
British terms they're so sweet and bring
out the tea cosy oh my god it's the bird
lady Ted yeah too busy feeding the bird
she forgot to feed herself know what I
love about these kind of British cockney
accent is that the best way you do just
fuck you it's like you're sipping tea so
didn't get acacia we're gonna get so
much right away I'm just thinking wow
that was terrible no it's okay because
we make fun of Americans just as much if
not more yeah Dick Van Dyke gets too
much shit for that oh he's still amazing
I don't think anyone doubts the
performance itself it's just the accent
his performance was it terrible I would
rather take a bad accent with a lot of
personality verses no way
acting at all so the Sean Connery method
yes I'm an Egyptian Spanish scholarship
is now on the street because she needs
to be in things to tell me what to think
she's like she's fine but you aware it's
is like when she walks in the room it's
like the goddess stepped in you know
what else I like honestly uh in the fact
there's opening credits at all I know be
uh the fact that's giving a preview of
what you're about to see which I love
seeing in movies it's like fuck ah give
a little preview have a little fun build
it up if you don't want spoilers don't
watch a film trailer at all cuz that's
all they do now instead though
everybody's like see the trailer and yet
they'll complain about spoilers okay how
does that happen especially when you
hear the words not again also he said
bloody I thought this is a kid I thought
that door was gonna hit that kid you
know it's like Jane and Michael were
already kind of reversible you could
give me their line to any of them now
you throw in a third one and they really
you can't tell one from the other full
disclosure I totally freaking forgot
there is a third yeah I didn't even
remember that I was like know this - oh
crap actually these two I love I
completely by their the kids growing up
they work well off each other
they're very charming very sympathetic I
really dig those two spruce that your
Garden Club society for the protection
of the rights of the underpaid citizens
of England see what we're doing that
thing where my mother was like a
progressive suffragette things I've been
doing it again you took her to learn
with fidelity fiduciary Bank fiduciary
Bank just hearing that maybe why I hear
the song again you need to be more
careful when the wind rises George you
would nearly lost your kite every why
should be accompanied by your clothes
and your face but it needs to be not
like a hard
your child abusable like this little
like just enough that they were just
just enough quick March and best foot
forward now thank you not to dawdle
well see she's a rock bitch as always I
should have left you in the umbrella
stand
I'm surprised you brought me back at all
now that David Tomlinson is dead that's
right dad boy think about that one
Poppins fans always they're drowning
three to say miss Lilly Poppins you're
messed up they run into the bed from
Bedknobs and Broomsticks bobbing along
Saddam Hussein songs are great what were
people talking about with those guys
like these are wonderful songs I agree
when the movie came out is like these
thongs and lackluster them like what are
you talking about that was a great
Sherman Brothers impression I'm a huge
Sherman Brothers fan boy so it's like I
like was really ready to unimpressed
let's just had a movie to support that's
no that's I think what killed it please
sorry we had an emotion father we'll go
back to being British this wouldn't
happen to be your sister would it mr.
banks so I saw this with my niece and my
brother-in-law my sister-in-law are
there she liked the movie just fine
she's a kid so I do remember these
scenes there was a lot of shifting
around like I'm just like fail okay how
old's that kite it would look even more
dirty everything is possible even the
impossible when you have the powers of
darkness edge aside Mary Poppins
what an honor it is to have you join us
this evening as soon as I saw that look
I'm like oh this is gonna suck they're
not gonna get it but it's not gonna be
that great in imitation like story okay
so the problem is like in those that
holding about don't judge a book by its
cover then you should have made him
really nice and not giving us that tip
off there yeah I give us that tip-off if
that's the point of the song god it's
sort of seen so many musicals where when
the song starts the movie grinds to a
halt yes the exact opposite yeah any
time they're not singing this movie's
just like Mary Poppins everybody I
couldn't believe I was watching this you
say this though is sitting in the
theater watching this with a bunch of
children I mean they woke up for this
part yeah this is ridiculous no it's so
fucking stupid like no Mary Poppins they
look at that that's so fucking stupid
they wake up in bed just sweating
they've had scarlet fever for days I
feel they've been hallucinating
where's Poppins children there is no
Mary Poppins there never was
I can't lose what you've never lost that
kid looked like he was gonna push a
button and a bomb was gonna go after he
said I tell understand feeling sick shit
puppets Marx Lenin the revolution has
begun Mary Poppins who doesn't listen
it's like the ultimate like super left
contradictions oh that is so offensive
but it's Meryl Streep oh I don't know
it's a joke she found the perfect way
around it it can't be offensive if you
don't know what it is yeah I'll say this
I think she's honestly fine in this
there's a lot of actresses who people
you're aware it's a performance it's
fine but it's like there's so many
actresses that could just naturally be
this weird where's Carol Kane when you
need her hey yeah fuck how cool would it
be if Carol Carol Kane was in this
just once you're like dealing out drug
source I don't like it first time on bad
sounds dear cuz any idea how much
eyeball might be worse not very much I'm
afraid my mother always said it was
priceless well your mother's dead I have
no idea I don't know where this movie's
going or what was supposed to be
character-wise oh did I ever tell you
how the people's revolution will not be
televised something feels odd about just
her being at the bank it's like just two
very different entities it's like The
Exorcist like you don't go in that room
she doesn't come out of the room it's
like you just kind of keep it's over
it's like when she goes to the bank it's
like that feels new it would it would be
like Linda Blair as like possessed
Pazuzu just wandering around in a
7-eleven yeah
fool stop this is so fucking stupid
yeah no no there has to be a twist it
has to be all the kids see like it can't
be this stupid like just what a slap in
the face of the original to do a story
this dumb not another word
and I hate this shit too when the kids
have the truth but the parent just
doesn't listen oh I'm just so easy so
like God what Mary Poppins to do that
when I was watching this like this was
the moment where I'm like okay I'm
actively getting angry okay this is the
road we're going that they're not gonna
bounce back from this they're just gonna
be this no and again aren't you noticing
when there's not a song oh yeah it's
like in the original there were so many
of there so perfectly spaced out and you
know we made this to them that's the
weird thing like the original Mary
Poppins is the same length as this or
longer longer longer and it feels
shorter yeah feel so much shorter okay
to take this idea the lights okay go
down the street a whole street of lights
they pick on this the lamppost they
fling them around but the lights are
still on is yeah you know so my oh you
know this is
we're watching what those fandom events
were like Newsies live this could be the
performance at the Academy Awards they
do for like you know the best songs or
whatever on this a thousand audience
like and this was on stage ever I'd be
like wow cool but in a movie you're
right all these shots do not show it off
it was on stage yeah this is a movie and
yeah something this guy never gets and
it drives me up the wall that's looking
a little Charlotte's bill there a little
what an effing you will be oh yes is
this what we're doing is he a strict
father wait yeah no because we gotta
bring him back to the original mr. banks
for reasons even though he seems quite
different earlier on in the movie yeah I
thought I was he didn't have enough
response no but no the last part of this
movie is where like all of the goodwill
was building with a lot of the song
started to fade away and I'm like oh my
god like this is unraveling fast I know
they're children my children and I will
deal with them as I see fit
get me a belt got something he would
like to give you mr. banker a patoot Oh
it's the HMS pitiful thank you thank you
wait last will and testament leaves it
to his friends no we have to do is turn
back time cut the dead to look like your
turn back time Jose like she flies
around the world backwards make as much
sense what don't look like the bad guys
in this yeah we're gonna make brixon
happen once and for all I liked this it
like this is whimsical yeah this is cute
it's physically impossible but I'm like
it's my idea and then she fucking sails
in any way and I'm like well what were
you wasting your time with this for it
cuts afro load leaving so soon
huh be him more amazing if it was the
banker caliber
[Laughter]
Big Ben is finally got it right yeah
that's so sad that now is the biggest
emotion yeah and it is signed
professor moneybags no it's monopolies
you have no bank shares no house
you have nothing I mean for taking a
mustache I knew it was fake all along
there was it that's mine let's marvel at
the fact that he now looks in real life
why exactly like the makeup they put out
him in the 60s to make him old which
tells me that's an Academy Award winning
makeup job that they did back then god
bless them and when he dies I'm gonna be
so depressed but that's my theory
I think he did die he's just still going
his heart stop want to keep going I will
die I do kind of really like the sequels
such a crime and true said it's a sham
go see Aquaman your very finest balloon
shoes carefully my dear he ducks many
have chosen wrong than do I just want
someone to grab it they just explain
she's pulling revolution hail Hydra and
with the bourgeoisie okay tell me you
don't want to see Kermit and Fozzie cup
we a comedy mystery yeah as well and
that was one note such misery
the devil has claimed your house leave
leave this place of doom your work is
done Poppins ascend to my kingdom Jack
was killed in workers riots shortly
thereafter Jane was imprisoned
Michael despondent but for the bank
manager he found a new job elsewhere he
invested in balloons and his dogs what
nowhere but up yeah look at that I tried
to do the credits exactly like I like
you just watch I'll marry Poppins yeah I
don't like TV movie credits though ya
know
ding gourami everything I liked about I
still I still like the songs now I'm in
the same boat like I still like it more
than you do but yeah it's like the songs
that are keeping it above water for me
it it's so weird how much miss potential
miss your pants what's weird cuz I
wasn't really looking weirdness of the
pattern yeah note for note like okay
this is the was supposed to be this is
the bit creepy Ali seen this is the step
in time Xena's everything they kept was
too familiar than everything they'd
changed didn't add anything it only took
away from what made the story so special
ah no no like you know like II so like
you the songs but but that's about it
so um yeah that's about it um I'm sure
we can get some good stuff we'll see you
guys next time data before we do that
let me make one thing perfectly clear I
don't have to explain anything
you